oh
[Musique]
je suis plus là merci de nous accorder
cette entrevue enchanté ont chanté puis
bienvenue encore merci ça fait déjà
trois mois que ces manifestations la
dure ça a l'air de s'installer
d'ailleurs pour continuer encore un bout
de temps est ce que ça vous inquiète ce
que ça vous fait peur
en fait ça m'inquiète pas sa matrice
plus qu'autre chose parce que ça fait
déjà 40 ans choquant j'adore cette ville
ça m'a donné des opportunités
incroyables et je suis triste du fait
que ce que j'ai vécu des moments
exceptionnels a encore malheureusement
on passe intérieure difficile
actuellement et c'est ça qui m'a écrit
savoir tout ça m'inquiète pas je pense
que c'est bon pour pour quelques
quelques sociétés qui à un moment donné
il fait face à des défis qu'il puisse se
réveiller et plus en parler et ça c'est
une bonne chose s'il fait qu'on puisse
en parler
donc ça ça m'inquiète pas mais ça
m'attriste c'est sûr vous avais pas
songé à partir quand même non absolument
pas
mais qu'est ce que vous en pensez de ces
manifestations de ce mouvement de
contestation là tout ça a été assez
exceptionnelle et la façon que ça a été
menée le fait qu'il ya un million deux
millions de personnes un million cinq
cent mille personnes qui marchent à dans
cette discipline à et qui exprime son
opinion sans nécessairement détruire
quoi que ce soit ah ça c'est assez
incroyable et c'est tout c'est toujours
ça que j'ai connue l'an quand les gens
l'on compte sur la discipline et sont
sont ils veulent avoir une harmonie mais
à un moment donné éclate il ya trop de
pression mais c'est quand même classé
une place où il ya beaucoup de pression
les gens sont quand même assez à l'e3 et
donc ça crée des situations qu'on vit
actuellement j'imagine est ce que vous
diriez que ce mouvement est donc vous il
ya beaucoup beaucoup de monde dans la
rue
alors est ce que c'est un mouvement qui
est soutenu par la population selon vous
absolument écouter à 1.7 millions de
personnes qui sont là qui étaient là où
1.5 million de personnes dimanche
dernier en général et en général les
gens sont en sympathie avec avec les
étudiants sont pensés hépatique la
violence ça va de soi et les gens
vandier si les démonstrateurs son
violent que la police réagissent de la
même façon ils ont aucun problème ex
mais ça fait mal quand même à l'économie
de hong kong non oui mais je pense que
n'importe quel pays n'est pas l'économie
passe par des périodes semble à des
réajustements quoi que ce soit écoutez
on a eu quand même le ska dans 2003 h à
finir le corps n'est donc comme ça a été
pénible
donc s'il ya vingt ans de ça je pense
que n'importe quelle économie doit
passer de réajustement et parfois ces
politiques qui influencent le côté
économique mais écoutez on compte n'y
est pas et pan des arguments qu'on
puisse permettre d'avoir des périodes
d'ajustement c'est pas dramatique et
et j'imagine que l'on va passer à
travers de ça mais ça va peut-être une
bonne chose que je qui se passe
actuellement aux comptes
ça va faire réfléchir le gouvernement
qui malheureusement au vu des gens
semblent être un gouvernement des riches
et la communauté des gens d'affaires
parce que quand même ils sont saouls qui
en subissent peut-être un peu les
conséquences ici on les entend pas
beaucoup les le gouvernement de pékin a
dit ben la forêt que chacun choisit son
camp donc est-ce qu'elle a soutenu les
manifestants et maintenant l'immeuble il
soutient plus comme en venant les
situations non je pense que parce que la
société polarisée divisé dédiant donc
les hommes d'affaires à la question un
succès très très très présent dans
l'économie locale
on peut oser prendre position parce
qu'il ya un élément de sympathie avec
jamais si des gens d'ici des jeunes ça
fait leur fils leur leurs neveux et
nièces ou quoi que ce soit qui sont là
et surtout temps si longtemps que ce
soit des démonstrations qui sont pas
violents ils doivent faire avec à la
chine
et parce qu'ils dérivent tellement de
bénéfices spectre avec le marché chinois
et d'autre part ils aiment bien ce que
hong kong et il aime ce que hong kong
était comme comme comme valeur
[Musique]
vous
à quel point les liens entre hong kong
et la chine sont importants les liens
sont et pendant je dois admettre que la
chine a fait beaucoup plus pour un
compte que ce que l'angleterre a fait
pour l'encan est donc dans quelle mesure
d'en mesurer aux suppliques onomique
c'est extraordinaire ce que les chinois
on perd on fait ici on simplement permis
aux chinois de venir encore on investit
boucan gang m'ont donné moins permis de
séjour permanent alors que sous le
régime anglais
j'avais pas de permis de séjour
permanent les chinois permet ça les
chinois ont permis une certaine forme de
démocratie ce que les anglais ou jamais
permis alors alors donc les chinois ont
fait beaucoup pour un con et je pense
que ce que les gens dont on espérer de
la part de la chine
c'est qu'ils coûtaient ya on a un projet
de 50 ans qu'on maintienne se
reconnaissait cette tentative de 50 ans
plutôt que d'intervenir trop tôt et
l'impression actuellement des gens dans
le corps
c'est que la chine peut-être intervient
un peu trop sur un camp alors qu'elle a
fait cette promesse de saint quentin
c'est tout la chine à un moment a là une
occasion exceptionnelle de de tenter de
tout utiliser un con comme un
laboratoire et quand même si c'est une
zone qui était qui est délimitée
précisément il est jenson sont produits
à l'étranger et aux études sont bien
éduqués à hong kong donc pourquoi pas de
tenter d'en être tentés la route
démocratique et à quel point hong kong
est important pour la chine par ailleurs
est-ce que ça reste une fenêtre sur le
monde pour la chine est ce que ça reste
aussi important ou bien est-ce qu'on le
perd un peu de son importance à ce que
hong kong perd de ce2 sont importants le
père doucement soir juste là la
proportion du pib de la chine sa abaissé
considérablement 2 5% s'est rendu kwame
mais et tout pas écouter ce qui est
intéressant ce que vous dites la
rencontre toujours demeurer pour la
chine ce que new york et londres new
york et pour les états unis est long
pour l'angleterre
l'ong s'est pas de plus de l'angleterre
mais l'on sait aux yeux des gens c'est
l'angleterre
comment vous voyez la fin de cette crise
vous pensez qu'il ya une solution
possible une solution possible ce qui
suit va y avoir une solution a eu un
changement de donner de chiffres je
pense qu'à un moment donné ça va être
important parce que non mais des gens
compétents ont coûté sinon est ce qu on
serait aussi prospère qu'il est
actuellement non
donc il ya des gens compétents des gens
éduqués il ya ya ya une volonté de la
population de que le gouvernement
travaille en leur faveur
il y aurait évidemment si la démocratie
était possible ce serait raide ce serait
idéal et qui est qu un programme
vigoureux de développement immobilier
social qu'il le fasse
des gens ont fait des sous qu'ils ne
fassent une société harmonieuse est une
société prospecte alors on verra ce qui
va se passer merci beaucoup monsieur
coyotes enchanté plus et revenez nous
voir encore les aides aux voix